lyrics by we are to discuss the
management of infection of a commitment
twists complex america acronym consists
offered plasma with aden functions
that includes i phillies and various stars
per by ruspi advice mina in gene
listeriosi hanckock sacchi beirut
ar
ruben la vyrus ti stai  you megaro vyrus
simplex vyrus one and her to the complex
include cruz in the face transmits award
women the fitus miur impregnates
this infection o during the delivery and
she's the green in tallinn I do this
weak natal infections history in
declined in the face I consider myself top
si plasma goal by newman hedges problem
by rossa anne harvard wirelss by
nineteen in ruin tal infections
include simplex and vyrus one hand and
this is like it would like to show and ex
temple of clinical and infection in
particular veined the history of human
vital signs infection  ed vyrus in furs
present in maternal to plug in phev de
trophoblasts fi broblasts and is viable in
bottle cells and a  fter the
replication in the presente the byrds
into the per guide fetal blood and at
this point per di cui serves definite
the commitment in tori natal infections the
compact between the google tende
infected materna gentastria one pass
through the bertana seems to be de mort
come  way of transmission for simplex one
man show in this light and youth like to
take out the potential disease
in fitusi andy new goals and after the
congenital and her provinata the infected
in particular in topless moses
vestimenti the weight of congenita
infection is free out of  the town center
of lies birds is in infected you don't we
hope serve is different symptoms in
particular hydrocefalus intro cyber
classification earring aids together ss
here observe them the wait congenital
infection del global reit is a 0 point
sixty four out of one under box  live
graz in this case when we serve
infetti newman we can observer lo sant'angelo
weight fita goal means shaun is done
hopefully megali sensors ne  ural recalls
lost and marco stefani okular defez is given
corbella vyrus before the introduction
of ribella boxing united states is a
congenital rite tv infection was very
high in the board and one percent of pain
insists and in fact robella is from a
bowl escapes of the very different  sinton
for example birth weight that brought
splenomegaly purpura bolli jones to
pratt contino parts sense in one yesterday
was strong 7 years microsoft
ed ad ars and for pyros i speak
engine vyrus of the month baseball in
particular in the features in defects
the end
fitusi  very true king symptoms and
we can ab star of life demais sevirà
ninea hydro challenge heart failure guardian
who is old but is a candy afelio
enter a sketch daughter final four of
purina tallinn face a piece viruses
and insignificant and bible in particular
the boxers  de the risk of the transmission
leave in congenital infection del rey
taylor the do per cent less the birthplace
infection of the merits awake  there and you get
through and it's tax tele in
german face transmission this love is about
imperfect and when we cash and
infection unworthy bon art and the
transmission and we hope different
problems in particular the disease and
his ok analysis of the skin eyes
and world map e se fa light hysterica
nostrano se palaitis same minutes
the infected and involving multiball organs
now we are going to analyzed e individua
michael organism l in folk sample
toxoplasma gondii we know it is a para
site and it is the most common para  site
worldwide distribution and it is the
cobol su infettate o lo warm and blood and
honey moles and one poulter of the human
population islam croniche infetti and a
very important problema
very high risk and transmission so we
know that day in the life cycle of sopra
smuggle  di and the definitive oste is
the cat and intermedia intermediate between
the mobile and also human and for
the risk of the transmission and in the
first master we can b  and with aise harris
who about fi percent and power on the
sidelines awarded the weekend of
transmission in this case of the risk for
civil congenital toxoplasmosis in the new
high and one weekend of athens reproach
in tackle
quarter after all the smash one is why are about
to  to si constitute partente batte in this
case we can rico nyse alu risk for
ladles congenital toxoplasmosis wrists and
bsb and that the great del global reit 0
point sixty four per sainte anne un
frame ten tuffi team percent of infetti
new bones we shall be seen tones  disk
rupe dei mortali curated about tender
sente and the twin peaks e tu stai 20
percent of them and go on to the blob
sibili sequele in a del parto per group
e ti fai 20 percent of è asymptomatica e
di gruppo e it to fifty percent of  them
and go on to the veil possible if that
and in particular sensori neural cirillo
and mint a lui target show in we know
that he about to out of one thousand
words a far from a congenital simbin
fede congenita  sim infection is
really important public health
problems and think it is in the number of
google suite congenital simbin fashion
per here is back
the united states another part of the word
nei fumi united states the number is
very high between twentieth century per
cause in  the new balance infected in
humans in brazil aboud helfer ti fai
house new goals and e in india about to
mud and theft cause interna and today
the congenital in fashion is the
non non genetic living of darkness in children
and more than half of the lisbon uil
symptomatic infection time or
asymptomatic
you will be loved by you know sensors
kirill of witches progress in fifty
percent of crisis and in june is the
national civil oneness mons for the
congenita semi in fashion and design is
a very very important action because we
know that  only snipers center of women
know about siepi in prize women and we
came conai
giulio impregna si sa primer infection
holland un primer infection in
particular a ring fashion
and has his del the byrds scope smith
for the mother to the features frw out
the placenta and activation and this moment stupid
vital infection on the risk of
congenital infection following primary and
non primary infection of a impregnate
is very high timer infection  and it is
the queen partitu fifty percent frw out
the pines except in della spal
dege station augury mechanize harris
che i quel tulsa 20 percent and don't
press infection rewrote about 0 then
the files to one forever claut di
pregasi and for primary and non primal  in
fashion and the risk du cap sinton ed ai
when the transmission occurred
les premiers in particular in the fur
quarter of the premier si and high
risk for the mean handicap
when the transmission ran in party
elden fox quarter de france suez now
look  at the pooh bella vyrus and the
byrds press by droplet from per hoped
the clapperboard and transmission and ran for days
before and steve intendesse  autre offset
offers mash and we and canucks dei files
concentration of bayern used in the end
and respiratory everything incubation
beak bess you is about thirteen days
and about the crickets in b al boca
lussuosa è lymphoids show device price and
dia sap tic system leeden tuber  line
is in systems that in fashion and the risk
of peter transmission is very bel haj in
the first time est and on casey in
yesterday's stable with eyes and risk of hattie and
juan percent of of new born in this risk
de criste by christine del  premier
stops and in particular after party is
undergoing station here
we can a hope serve and increase of the
week that the more that both risks the
nanda per sente some symptom and the
risk to caps on tour in infected fitusi
andrews bel haj when the  broadcast
races in deduction sports or pay in
particular in the beatles quarter
after seeds nor weeks
the station games stukas intonse in new
born and rain fitusi sandy new mall il 0
infection dell'in  fection engage
ford welfare of the station mi
serve a very low risk and two pair
congenital infection and and risk and is
equal to hate percent n in this case
and a bag has effects of battle with
housing tones pende non risk and when
the  transmission wen sony maternal
to the infection in after quarter
us hull of the conception to the roubaix
line fashion and risk for accident at the
bazi nation of yuri premier to the buses from
some matches and of the spec from the
world health protection agency end in
week not needed in disney that  the day
congenital the median incidence of
congenita bella syndrome de criste in
the last years in particular te christe
qui in nine t nine the six and two
thousand is in trend and in particular in
a regions and the baxi nation n we have
a very good bella  baxin come range dei
gate di con gene rubello syndrome the
bay aic incidence of the rest is
localized in south and east
e john and dance africa we
Sapereimportant point  it is only beautiful in
particular for the burden of congenital
robella syndrome because he in this is
it is al softball tooth here they are tricks
go there in style enter the world with
disabilities of congenital robella
syndrome the spider a
dell'abilissimo effects and safe
and her ai agree with this sentence and
web di possibili to use the baxin end ai
film this is the best away enormous to
eliminate and a disabilities you tube is
congenital ruben ha indeed on ibook dai
to show now clinic and kate and disease a
isla follow  up
c'è chi pur in new born in this
in otto umberto causin skin and the new
born a positive and foro bella vyrus end
si sente a congenita roubaix nasino tema
there was a nigeria and da wired in italy
and the weinstein weeks o premier si  and
bass intonse wars interstitial chino
monia steal the muffins rush rombo santo
pinecone and putt ichthys and the brain
magneti winston hans imaging
demonstrated appeared pr alteration of
the brain and di proble  mi ed weekend in
two two years before and into cause the
sixteen and ice and disease itself set
ball so we are going to discuss the pagu
vyrus b nineteen problems in particular
in this light ai would like to shore
some pictures of children with this is
you to the bar vyrus living in
infection e su chi si sitratti we can
observe the typical la hit and you tube
you to the disease attack baus pina in
china
and this is an actor ore a bellizzi br
exist in fitto pesa ai trough the
parlo vyrus  disease and sun fax febo di te
materna al infection parco pyros binenti
in sé translation of the byrds with the
mother to the feature nd fitta disease's
in particular and we can rico nyse a
cargo nice al set up the season al in
template climate lasting about six
months del long term cyclical variation
with the day two for years and we know
that look si matri e forti percent of
women of child and age aluminum for
parco vyrus mia in china.la proxy matri
fifty percent of infant cha  nce but
asymptomatic thermal infection the
vertical transmission is about parks to
feel and avoid losses about that
the sun and time feel good and maternal
infection occurred in the first and
twenty bewick soft station finally we
know that the morning if siro convention
in crisis  during the season al e epidemic
che orioles indeed we can o pseudo del
materna materna siro convention and we
can ab serve a risks e quartu tender
stent versus juan poi fighters health
and disease del ris che in no season at the
epidemic york
finally and we 11 feb
the meat is beautifully in infected end
indeed the avenue forza pure capi
simplex vyrus and we came with eyes and
type one and take two taiwan predominate
in gold fashion nations unies typical i
found in the trigemine gang ea tar
turismo as i found in the long tires
large mr teles di smart scan in fact
the board horror fashion areas and e
genital tract and we know that arti
genital is the man risk for neonata
lampis i  n about seventeen haiti for
feels protected in pot for those
leaving meanwhile one and for the risk
code transmission ismar important to me
with eyes del wii different types of
trenitalia infection in the fest fest
episode ai main fashion and occurred in
person
yes but negative for both  team black swan
and campi sting click to antibodies è
disperso acquires e inter vyrus indigeni
tal tract nel second camisa episode non
temer infection in di scales the
person is sia sì meeting perhaps simplex
one hand e acqua ars artists and back to
the genital tract of the applicant  in the
face is the typical de bari activation
phone latency enzo frequent also greto
to his che show 9 barus back to the skin
n everything and surprised in particular in
the genital so many are in disuse of the
risk off
the blood of newborn harper tease verify
in magners  league
episode of the nigth al 7 si blacks
vyrus infection di alterne del madre
with coniuge l'italservice esito si
indispettì ball indie fe  st episodes and
handhelds and does not reward infection
greenpeace about to perfect rents and a
grudge in more fashion between 0
tuffo utis the current torch screening
situation in europe and abroad theft
hoxton four tops and it is mandatory in
a countries in wet and
more screening  linde finance i m in europe week
have only in scene of the crime in the
new goals and other countries in europe
it is not recommended and it is not
mangers pure yes and b screening today's
routine anti born turns off falls in via a
prize women and by years public
authority in eni and the european and
non european countries where in this
moment in germany svitzer lande se in
vissero logic testing will come the kind
of the association medical society so it
is a averi and this is the screen in tema
tender screening bears and behind  this
moment is very particular moments of
things in the
tooth in different countries a hard
disk casting of the useful kind of screen
and ordered ode to you been written in
i  taly the majority of physicians the
three chance di testa e ne women for
sure in the first remittance to the premier he
was in fact in italy about forti per sente
id est mordente cause di porsi e di
antibodies in particular ai gigi and
high gm antibodies l essere salvi
universe caskets of ca me quite common
corbella in europe the screen and his
raccomando materno spinesi recommends e
bay or il public health
autoreti in Europea european countries por par la vyrus binenti nscreen in europe and
there is no evidence for screening and
being evidence for materna spini  for
artists simplex viruses in this case in
particular important that va counseling
end in evolution tool sexually
transmissible and commitment women at risk so
now i'm like to complete del parto per
screening with the different management
and death cab for the horse and complex
in particular  ore e four tops and at
your impregnarsi il 6
quini in italy is the best is to check
and pregnant women and industry master
and if you have a negative laughter foray
gigi ed ai gm the cyber important and you
you you of rage in profiled majors and
the against much tasks more than be
green industry master special results
for high gigi gives ai gm very important
to check of the award  women with us e con
le tempeste in particular cui the
ability testi di cose in distese io
rende possibili tour e con ice tea
infetti in fact when you
che fare atti t index industry meste these results
exclude infection in the previous three
four months and law and  order and the
ability index camper sistel longer than
expected existing in toxoplasmosis
italia curious headquarters ai gigi pdt test but
still beconsider and is the exclusion test
end in well important
when you tweet prize women and you'll
be who test important to consider the
problem  of the treatment in particular
of hydrates despar a mine oramai sin toxo
plasma gondi invests production and
mature dresses shaun of antipasto plasma
gondi specific to the people  antibodies
and tools airports for difference
patience treatment
black line è il pesce l'udinese de the
treatment de mature shaun reserve
tiffert o file gt antibodies maybe e b
and testing is the best is to use the
eye gigi and high gm antibodies testi in
the  first trimester si sole aubry with
eyes of four categories categories way you
are a gigi and high gm active and it is
is indicative off not in a woman and
this woman's high risk of a quy nhon
press in the face of a impregnate in
this case teese  mandatory of information
on aging and friends horse and very very
important and when you che ed speciali
results still ai ggn hajjam negative
results in particular quarter or
before sixty wings of the station is
indicative or pasta in the face and don't do
dai ernesti investigation is required
wine  youtube a negative results and high
gigi appropria results for high gm in
particular the pi for today a
soak n indicative of a cure weight
primer infected or  huygen for sposi che
results and is the rise super important
of a 0 logical seconds ecological
testing and testing is important
blair after the fifth
days later finally web
indicative active
fashion and cool indicates to press or not
brake desist rice in various
important bars josé hoffer
and a second level of theological test in
particular important of a pdt ai cc
testing both airports and mac sample of
the clean ethic si mba gigi mature shaun
and  wine news am di testing in part of
the premier si dei sensi tvt
identification premium e turris
cauto smith in the vyrus to the features bel
air one da percent of use this testing
instead con parte del bagno se up to any
to any which he special sensitivity
slowear is sexy per sette su when you
use the senologica advanced diagnose iss
in particole ability test in fossi in b
interforce trimester before fortiswitch
station fire w  ith it index indicates no
current oreste un primer infection lo
abiliti index index a chiuda soon in
premier in fashion the closet attention
what I think when the level of high
gigi antibodies flory law and her with
un automezzi per ai gigi er btt test in dettagli
e  con ice sun pictures of
aig tip and turns and in particular
when the very low ai gigi levels the past
infection and this post
and you use the ability testing exposed
ball tour
i bulls lo abiliti when you get low
level of age ii antibodies in also
face off prime in viso in this case
is very easy to air force high ability
case the
results are under il vano and
shawnspagnoli finally would like to discuss
the management of sul bel infection in
particular why wait and how why it is
important to offer ba  xi nation disease
and desist and horizon there you are important
you screen that the women before the
premier si and is important hoffer baxi
nation tour seronegative women of child
bering age and and if you don't have an
surrender before the pregna si its mandate
l'  itu scrignoli of the premier yes of the
prize women and in case of ser negative
women and be negative
uli mense for all the premises
of the import of the post partum
immunization bina in team ternano
infection and the very important
laboratory testing that you use
had logic al  testing and in
particular detention o poi gigi end e i
giramenti bodies end ai furbi nineteen
fondamenta g20 in in france violo in
finance airports in this light the mac
home and action fund and society di
ostriche e inganni ecologiste in
particular when you have a un'astens
ex post or white homme a the wings
untouched for import tester stage vyrus
bidentina ai gt ed ai gm renders the film
the only way every when you and special
re  sults for high gigi and high gm or
negative
premier se m
abnormal ultrasound findings indifese
it is mandatory end in media tweet a
test prize women with the breast
testing and negative
gigi and time antibodies and this is not
the problem of bijoux de palo vice
bennent in matisse beautiful important
other things the more that  positive to gigi
and high gm with special to gigi and
negative agi mi3 severe in door of
skate of a new synthesis or synthesis fitting
if it is true
said chu seat is different fine boiler
with uses the pensa of the year and
disease and in the features  pinal him
and it is dell'aspro far commendation è
dell'astice for simplex vyrus in the face
in particular it is the most oenological test quiz
al test in the mother and i
you tube apposi  ti results for high gigi
air one and type two and i più
che positive jazz is better to complete e
del follow up with testing and full high
gigi oli against archi simplex to end e
because he exposed volturo in con ice
the kind of the infetto il  river a
negative results and the first screening
it is indicative of assiro negative
mother and no infected or simplex vyrus
one hand and in conclude mai mai
presentation mai seminar and high would
like to find that michael hicks and hurd
department of my hospital and it is  a
hospital of the universe bologna and
ipod mai potuta hankyu fuori una patch
thank you
the nation of this is the best use of
testing e mark ii
il premier si e mater di
impresa test gigi ngm antibodies women's negative
Important continuous follow up and very
important halls  of it is mandatory test
of the women in the family award
we know that there is a turkish relation
between the different commercial abele
ball kids and fun time with possibility
is different  rente resenze between the
different the note is in the ex coach it
is sent to the cgia see the tests in the box the
jeans mandatory dresses in gigi text in
strength and be in the first week station
well to wheel of the station and we know
that he more heads  ior e science iore
prize women the first time after city
widget station exposed would lead to
maybe perhaps you have dresses t index and this
is the horizon verde psychics that of
this testing after sixteen ei kiwi ge
station is very low in order to identify
beyond new rime and  dai ris is important
because of the only two the primer
infections in particular in trimester
offers and it is mandatory x70 logic
tester for pyros and gigi and high gm and
it is important to the situation in
particular
but there have seen tones in correlation
with pardo vhils  di rankin or in church
expo show possible in particular of
planet al the year news
ok end of ascent exists in if you and
the defense under severity of it this is
it offers a my synthesis  apro like ma
chinese fluide i più hoffer cordo
synthesis in this case we the most e
appropriate ma gira is not only amiotti
fluide parte porta to consider the feet
alla the jay